hi and welcome I'm Nomi Prins I'm here
today with Jake Halpern the author of
the fascinating and horrifying new book
bad paper chasing debt from Wall Street
to the underworld
Jake welcome thanks for having me thank
you this book is incredible and and so
is your story and I think the two really
mirror each other this takes place in
Buffalo New York a lot of it and you're
from there aren't you yeah that's right
I grew up there and my dad and his wife
still live there I go back there fairly
often and it's kind of how I find my way
into this world you talk about a
particular and many unsavory characters
that are scrambling to make their own
peace of the world and often have prison
records and have been drug dealers and
so forth there's a fellow named Jimmy
that comes out here that seems to be one
of the main characters of this
nonfiction story he talked to me a
little bit about how you connected with
him yeah so the way this got started was
I was talking to my mom a few years back
and she told me she was being hounded by
a debt collector and she said I don't
owe the money that he's saying I owe but
I think I'm gonna pay him just say he'll
stop harassing me which my mom is like
no builting Willy so I thought this is
bizarre and I started googling it and
saw that there was a lot of this kind of
going on and that actually the epicenter
of debt collections in general in the
United States was Buffalo or is one of
the big hubs so I had in my head that I
was gonna do a story actually from the
collectors perspective and what's it
like to collect debt what are the
challenges you face what's your life
like so I pitched the story into The New
Yorker just kind of bare bones saying
like what do you think about this I'm
from Buffalo I could probably get
someone to talk to me and my editor said
great
five thousand words when can you get me
copy so I kind of panicked cuz I had
nothing so I went to Buffalo once and no
one would talk to me basically and I
went a second time and I still had
nothing and so I started to panic
because I was on the hook for this story
so I went on Facebook and I just
sent messages to everyone I went to high
school with and then everyone my brother
went to high school with and I get one
message back from this guy was actually
Jimmy's brother and I got Jimmy on the
phone and Jimmy said to me basically you
better get down here quick if you want
to talk to me because my but my business
is in struggling I don't know how much
longer I'll be open but if you can like
show folks how hard my day-to-day life
is I'll be satisfied so I popped down to
Buffalo showed up and Jimmy just was
immediately one of these amazing
characters it was just eloquent and
emotive and I'm driving around and it's
car with him going to church with him
and meeting his family and that becomes
kind of my entry point into this world
and he had a struggle you knew him
growing up as well you got to him
through a set of correspondences through
Facebook and so forth
get your history in Buffalo yes the
atmosphere in Buffalo how it's changed
from what you knew growing up and in
your childhood to the kind of place that
it's one of the capitals right of
debt-collection the United States how
did that yeah so I mean Buffalo was once
this big industrial powerhouse it had
all these steel mills in all this
industry and starting in the late 70s
and early 80's basically when I was a
kid that all starts to fall apart and
unemployment goes to the roof and in
place of a lot of these old industrial
jobs collections kind of fills that void
someone told me that Buffalo is so good
at collections because even though the
country has been in a great recession
since 2008 Buffalo has been in it since
1979 and people there you know can
connect with with people who were having
a hard time so I when I was kind of a
teenager even this was starting to kind
of take form but I don't think I really
knew about it and and even though I went
to high school with Jimmy we went to the
same high school and it was supposed to
be an integrated high school we came
from opposite sides of Main Street and
Buffalo is a fairly segregated city and
I didn't have any sense of what really
what life on the east side of Buffalo
was like or what Jimmy was going through
and even though we could talk about
having the same English teacher it was
like we were from totally different
worlds and it was until I started
reporting the story that all of a sudden
I knew that
learn that when he was in high school
his father was a heroin addict that
after getting out of high school he had
become a cocaine dealer had gone to jail
on a gun possession and you know our
lives couldn't have kind of been more
divergent so he you said is the entry
point into the rest of the store and he
of course has a very interesting
component of this story through
something that you call the package
right which seems to be the crux of what
the what you're chasing and and what the
debt collectors are effectively chasing
and involved in in the book and you kind
of talk about his relationship what the
package is right and how that opened up
the rest of this amazing story oh yeah
so yeah so the package is this one piece
of debt that I follow through the book
and it's I think helpful to understand
that when I talk about debt that's being
bought and sold here we're really just
talking about an Excel spreadsheet so
you have the big banks or creditors and
they try for say six months to collect
on a debt that's not been paid and when
they can't they'll typically sell it off
for pennies on a dollar to to debt
buyers and those debt buyers will
collect whatever they can then sell to
the next and the next and the next and
what they're selling is just as they
said a spreadsheet with the bare bones
information this information on
customers on their balances on where
they live so like you look at the
spreadsheet will have debtors name
social security number address balance
date that the account was opened maybe
one or two other fields but that's
basically about it and they're just
being bought and sold an email they're
sent by thumb drives and that's that is
the the paper they call it paper but
that's really all that it is and as you
can imagine it doesn't take much for
something to go wrong for some of the
fields in the to get mixed up the
amounts the debtors names to get
confused or for someone to sell the same
Excel spreadsheet to multiple
unsuspecting buyers who are all
collecting on it at once so in my book I
followed the package and what I call the
package there's one piece of debt it's
about 48 million dollars and it's face
value but which is bought for pennies on
the dollar by this debt buyer in Buffalo
his name is Erin Siegel and what happens
is this piece of debt gets stolen
somehow Erin finds out from his coal
they start calling them saying Aaron's
something weird is going on with these
accounts it appears that somebody else
has access this information and is
collecting the money from the debtors on
this package before we get to them so at
that point he calls his fixer who is a
guy named Brandon Wilson who is a kind
of his unofficial partner who's a former
bank robber who's kind of gotten into
this business helps him buy and sell
debt but also helps him solve these
sorts of problems and it's Brandon who
then goes and tracks down the thieves
that have a prat that have gotten ahold
of this debt and retrieves it and we can
talk about
it's a crazy showdown with guns and they
get it back but the world in which he
must go to to retrieve that debt that's
the world that Jimmy inhabits which is
this kind of gray area of legality kind
of underworld of buying and selling
debts and kind of sketchy man or that
exists in Buffalo and in other places
right and and this this underworld has
that that hierarchy you mention it there
you have sort of former thugs to a large
extent at the bottom yeah level getting
some of this paper that is perhaps been
sold and resold and I also talked about
how paper has been stolen yeah as well
and then you have sort of the level up
through Erin Siegel and he seems really
an interesting character to me I'd like
to to kind of talk about how you got to
him through Jimmy and also the through
the package and also he wasn't a thug he
grew up on the on the good side that's
right right he had a wealthy family
upbringing lived in a mansion right so
how did he come into the same business
right so the story really start the way
that I tell the story in the book it
starts with this guy Aaron Siegel and
Aaron grew up in a wealthy and very
well-known and well-respected family in
Buffalo he goes to Wall Street for a
while as a banker even does a some time
in London and decides he wants to come
home and be closer to his family and he
ends up working at an office of Bank of
America and Buffalo but around the time
that he comes back what's happening is
is that throughout Buffalo entrepreneurs
are buying some debt they're buying this
paper these spreadsheets and then
opening up a shop or they hire a bunch
of collectors to collect
and the profit margin this is right
before the kind of great reshef
recession happens his profit margins
initially when he gets into this
business or through the roof
he's like buying a portfolio of debt for
30 grand and in three months making 90
grand so he realizes that he's kind of
found this amazing little niche of the
finance world and his supply the key to
a much of his success is he's got this
supplier who's supplying him with this
paper and a really great price and it's
really lucrative the weird thing about
the supplier is he's this fellow Brandon
Wilson who's this former armed robber
who's done ten years in prison but has
reinvented himself as a debt broker
who's got this kind of genius for
finding paper that pays that is very
collectible and isn't that expensive to
buy and so even though Aaron kind of
comes from this very kind of more
rarefied world and has got this kind of
banking past he understands it in this
sector of the economy it's not unusual
to have some kind of shady or
connections or some guys that a rough
around the edges and so he and Brandon
formed this kind of unlikely friendship
and partnership and that's really the
starting point for further for the book
and for the story and talk about how
when they're looking for this paper
Aaron's looking for paper looking
through it for it through Brendon he
actually also buys a portfolio from his
old firm from Bank of America yeah that
you talk about as being that's a great a
portfolio but for reasons other than the
fact that it's been stolen and moved
around the block many times right so the
irony is a sir aaron is always the key
to making a profit margin in this world
is getting good paper everyone's hunting
for for good paper and when he buys from
his former employer Bank of America you
would think this would be as kind of
respectable and as dependable as it can
be he feels that the the Bank of America
really pulls a fast one on him because
he spends all this money millions of
dollars buying this this piece of debt
from Bank of America him it turns out
they're almost all senior citizens which
have the smallest amount of disposable
income and he feels that the Bank of
America failed him but the former armed
robber Brandon that he does business
with kind of comes through for him in a
way that his former employer doesn't
what does he do so he's really behind
8ball when he buys this Bank of America
paper and it's all these senior citizens
he he feels that he can't he's not gonna
be able to turn a profit because he's
invested all this money in them so he
goes to back to Brandon and Brandon
specialty is finding what he calls crap
and crap and Brandon's definition of it
is old debt that everyone thinks is is
worthless because it's been around the
block a few times have been bought and
sold a bunch it's 10 to 15 years old but
it still pays because maybe it was
sitting in a call center in Brazil for
five years and no one was working it or
maybe it comes from a debt buyer that is
about to go under and needs to sell it
off cheaply so Brandon would find these
little deals on this paper and so after
aaron buys his stuff from Bank of
America that really puts him behind the
8-ball
he turns to Brandon and says Brandon
you've got to come through for me and
really helped me find these deals on
this crap and this other stuff that you
find and then the package which we
talked about before which is this piece
of debt that gets stolen the package is
actually fantastic paper for Aaron it's
really good
he doesn't pay a lot for it it's it's
paying off for him and then of course it
gets stolen and you know he's like
alright you know Brandon go fix this
right and how Aaron even come up with
the money to buy the package I mean he
did okay he had a banking job he went
back to Buffalo who's behind sort of
funding the initial purchases of some of
these packages at the Aaron level right
so if Aaron's story is you know he's a
banker he's in New York comes back to
Buffalo sets up his own small collection
agency and with Brandon's help he's
getting this paper that's really paying
huge dividends so he like any good
financier starts thinking wow what if I
did this on a much larger scale so he
makes a few phone calls and finds eight
investors who give him 14 million
dollars to do a trial run the thinking
is if if he can do with this 14 million
dollars what he's done with his own
money
these three hundred percent returns and
whatnot then he'll do it even you know
bigger for this 14 million and the 14
million will then he'll do it a second
round with 40 million in bigger and
bigger the problem is is that you know
that there's several problems one of
which the Great Recession occurs
people don't have as much money and then
he encounters many problems along the
way including the theft of some of this
paper which you know I Chronicle in the
book and he so basically before that or
while that's happening he's in a hole
he's out some amount that's a proportion
of 14 million dollars he's got investors
on the other side squeezing him from
they want their money back you you
visited a couple of these investors
right how are they feeling about that
what was their stake in this and how
much were they pressuring him and how
much was it a portion of their own money
how much do they even care about what
happened really I think that they gave
Aaron it's funny cuz so I did want to
meet some Varun's investors and getting
kind of get a sense for for what their
take on this was and I went up to dinner
one night with one of them and so first
thing you have to understand is there's
this strange sequence of events the
debtors are owing Brandon who's
collecting on it Brandon's getting the
money he owes Aaron who's organizing the
fund Aaron then oh is the investors who
gave him the money so there's this
everyone is beholden to want to know
everyone is connected by this thing of
debt so when Aaron goes to meet one of
these investors is fellow named Joseph
he's he's he's totally anxious because
he feels that he's gonna fail this guy
and Oh him money and it turns out Joseph
just sees this almost as as he's just
popped him a million dollars to see he's
also put money into tanning tanning
salons and bars and for him Aaron said
he was hoping would pay off but it's
almost like an amusement and when we're
having dinner with Joseph I say do you
ever think about basically the people's
whose debts you're buying and he says no
why should I
they are they've made you know bad
financial choices is it my fault for
wanting to profit on and he makes the
analogy to a baseball game he says if a
pitcher pitches a bad pitch in the
batter
you knocks a triple it you know is the
batter somehow wrong for taking
advantage of the bat pitch and that was
Joseph's feeling about about the whole
situation but it was it was kind of
crazy to think that you know I met some
of the debtors and they're you know you
know a poor single woman living in st.
Louis is connected to this former armed
robber from Boston is connected to the
Buffalo Sion Aaron it was connected to
this wealthy investor and all of their
lives are connected by this chain of
debt but none of them really know one
another that whole aspect fascinated me
and the way the way you write about it
is it is so so clear it's like we're
there you know in your writing or you're
an excellent writer and you really are
not on the ground journalists as well
and that really helps to bring a lot of
these characters and also the locations
in which you're meeting some of these
people and you have gone around to meet
from that top of the chain the josephs
down to the bottom of the chain the
individuals that get really hurt and
involved over in this process and you
actually talk about some specific
individuals that are just numbers right
in this package they're just represented
as numbers that's right they have real
lives and you went and investigated and
spoke with some of them you mention a
woman named Teresa when Joanna who who
were at one point taking out credit and
and paying it and and then things
happened and they got involved in this
whole vortex right what was that I mean
you're absolutely right what's what so
it's being bought and sold here it's
easy to think of it almost as just as
some sort of commodity like coffee
shares or something because you're just
looking at these string of numbers on
these sheets and there's thousands of
them and this one paid and this one
didn't pay but you pause for a second
you think that this package of several
thousand lines on this excel spreadsheet
are basically several thousand stories
of people whose lives from one reason or
another have fallen into financial ruin
so I managed to get a hold of this
spreadsheet for the package that got
stolen and I was looking at it and I was
thinking to myself these are stories
here these these names and these numbers
represent something that's happened so I
started kind of reaching out to some of
these people in explaining I'm the
journalist I'm looking into this
particular piece of debt that I believe
was stolen and I want to hear her
stories and most people just hung up on
me but if you do who I profile on the
book talked and and what they said
Theresa the woman that you mentioned she
was a former Marine she had you know she
defies whatever stereotypes we have of a
debtor she had worked right through high
school helped helping her parents pay
off their mortgage and her life comes
apart after she gets out of the Marine
Corps she finds out that her husband is
cheating on her
she kicks him out of the house all of a
sudden she goes from being one income to
to income but she's still on the hook
for the for the vehicle payments and the
mortgage and she falls behind in her
bills
and at that point she stops the fees
start kicking in on this Washington
Mutual card which is the card that was
connected at the package late fees and
over-the-limit fees and eventually she
just can't pay anymore so unbeknownst to
her Washington Mutual sells off his debt
to a debt buyer and it ends up in Aaron
Siegel's hands in Buffalo and then it
ends up being stolen and in the hands of
these these guys that don't actually own
it so one day Teresa of course doesn't
know about this so one day she gets a
call and says ma'am you owe this money
and you need to pay this right now or
there's gonna be legal repercussions and
this is your chance to do it and the
calls get increasingly threatening
meanwhile Teresa has got a job working a
border patrol in the southwest and if
she doesn't have a credit in order it's
hard to have a job like that because you
can be you know blackmailed or there's
it's a liability right so Teresa is
thinking oh my god I'm gonna lose this
job what am I gonna do I'm just gonna
pay these guys off so she agrees to pay
$2,700 off in several installments she
feels good about it you know that she's
getting on top of it but when she makes
the last payment and she's expecting to
get some sort of receipt for what she
paid there's nothing and when she checks
to the credit reporting agencies there's
no record of her pain she has no idea
she assumed that she was paying people
why would you assume otherwise they had
all of her information but she's paid
people who stole her debt and these are
some of these are some of the people
that aaron and brandon realize are
paying the wrong guy so you're
absolutely right each one of these names
on this package of debt that gets stolen
are real people and the stakes couldn't
be much higher for what this means for
their lives and it seems like there are
so few rules or abilities from
regulators to really cover all of these
different points that you talk about
these individuals debt moving back and
forth when it does yeah and and people
like Teresa don't that they don't know
what's going on they're just they're
just afraid they're just paying because
of the phone call what kind of
Dick's are coming from that other side
of the phone call because almost a third
of Americans of debt right now is it are
in collection that's right so they may
be getting these phone calls from from
some of these people that you talk about
in your book what what is that like
what's there right so when uh so you're
right absolutely right about a third of
Americans have a debt in collections and
when you you're gonna call bad debt
collector basically what you get is the
talk off and the talk off is the
collector on one end trying to persuade
you to open your wall and pay your bill
so there's legal talk offs
there's illegal talk offs and there's
kind of a gray area so the legal talk
off would be you know just talking
through this is the information I you
you paid you know this amount of this
your social security number you need to
pay this how can we arrange this you
have to do this the illegal tactics are
when you're basically threatening and
lying to data to consumers saying we're
gonna take legal action when that is not
true we're going to arrest you we're
gonna seize your property lies and kind
of coercion and threats like that are
not legal and that that happens a fair
amount and if you think about it it
happens towards the bottom of the debt
food chain so if you have this piece of
debt the banks sell off to a fairly
reputable debt buyer they don't need to
do that to get their money out of it
fairly quickly but when that debt has
been bought and sold six and seven times
what you're left what it's whittled down
to are the folks that haven't paid any
of the previous six owners and the
people that get that debt are usually
the people at the very bottom of the
food chain and that's where they almost
feel if they have to make these very
threatening calls and these illegal
tactics in order to kind of squeeze the
money out of folks and there's often
these are these small agencies that open
up they do it and then they close back
down and then open up somewhere else
before they can be caught by the
authorities and I just want to say make
one other point which is that there's
not a lot of regulation and law
enforcement that exists it's changing it
is the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau and the state attorney generals
are starting to get more into this space
but within the last bunch of years there
hasn't been much regulation and thatx
explain why a banker like Aaron would
team up with a form
armed robber like Brandon because not
only is Brandon getting good paper
Brandon's basically offering him a
service that regulators and law
enforcement can which is when something
goes wrong I will solve this problem for
you because calling the police and
calling the State Attorney General and
calling the CFPB is not going to get it
done you need me Brandon Wilson to
straighten it out and I think that that
Aaron saw the the truth in that when you
make the comparison just in that you've
got you've got desperate people on one
side who are trying at the bottom of
their food chain to collect debts and
you have desperate individuals who are
getting these phone calls and are paying
because it sounds scary yeah and you
have very little regulation particularly
at the at the bottom yes part of this
chain so so what recourse do some of
these individuals have or or what can
they do besides where do they complain
what can they do if they've paid on a
debt yeah but it's gone to no one I mean
it's gone to basically some of these
people right I mean I was sitting in in
a shop was sitting in Jimmy's shop one
day in Buffalo this is a few years ago
and I was listening to the calls between
the collectors and the debtors and their
guy gets on the phone and Jimmy's trying
to collect from them and says hey you
owe money on this payday loan and the
guy said I just paid this payday loan
off three months ago paid $900 by the
way that was probably a $300 loan I just
paid it off and Jimmy said well can you
can you send me a written proof with a
receipt from that agency showing that
you proof and the and the guy said I
never got that and then Jimmy said to
him matter-of-factly we'll then sir I'm
afraid you still owe the money and he
turned to me and said I'm that this is
the only way that I know that that guy
is telling the truth I think if I just
forgave every debtor that said they had
paid I wouldn't be in business but
you've got a sense of the franticness of
the guy on the other line who who
sounded fairly earnest he had paid this
off and he didn't sound like he had much
much recourse
I think the calls will continue until
you pay kind of thing now there are one
or two things that are helpful for
consumers to know one is which is know
it the statute of limitations in your
state is for when a debt is no longer
legally enforceable and it varies some
say like three to six years but if
you're getting a call on a debt
it's four years old and the statute of
limitations in your state is three years
old then you have no legal obligation to
repay that debt
another thing is after seven years most
negative reporting falls off your credit
report the credit reporting agencies so
it's always it's safe to say that that's
that's very interesting I think
information for anyone out there yeah
getting these calls is is it is it safe
to say that if you do get a call yeah on
any level of threatening after five or
six years about a debt back then is it
safe to say you should I mean ignore
that call yeah I mean you may feel that
you have a moral obligation to repay it
but yeah I would be very if it were me I
would probably think twice about
repaying it if I know in a year it's
gonna go off my credit report rating
because it's been seven years or if
there's no legal recourse because it's
an out of step stat or beyond the
statute of limitations and the other
thing I would just say is I would want
to make sure the person on the other end
of the phone actually owns the dead I
would want to and that's there's not a
problem is there's not an easy way to
figure that out but you could get the
name of the company check them out on
the Better Business Bureau website and
get a sense for whether this seems like
a reputable company or not right you
actually were on a call you in as part
of your research for this book you
actually in one of these collection
centers and you got on the phone to sort
of feel like what it was to be a debt
collector and how that conversation with
this person at the other end of the
phone what was that like yeah so I was
at Brandon Wilson's collection agency
and we were up in Bangor Maine and I was
just observing and he said to me look
you got to get on the phones you can
observe all you want but you're not
gonna actually understand what this
job's like unless you collect and I was
kind of reluctant for a few reasons one
of which is I just didn't want to like
hound people but the other collectors
who worked for him started kind of
haranguing me and saying you've got to
try this and I said all right so I got
on the give me a headset I sat in front
of one of these terminals and they had
it on auto dialer so that debtors whose
contact information had been verified
would just route to me and so the first
call came to me and it was a woman who
owed I think like $450 on her cell phone
bill
and I said something like ma'am I see
you owe this $900 now with interest but
we can give you a reduced rate which you
consider paying this and I heard myself
saying and I thought I wouldn't pay me
that's such a weak opening gambit and
eventually we're talking and I'm trying
to Brandon's whole thing's gonna marry
the debtor which is that I have to have
such empathy that you know like what's
going on with you in your life you're
you're you're you're working and that
will have some sort of connection that
she'll feel like she can you know open
up and trust me and I'm trying to do
this and at one point she says well
maybe I could write you a check and but
I don't like seize on that right away
cuz I'm trying to marry her and and then
she hangs up and Brandon is right behind
me kind of playing you know coach and
he's like look you've you failed at this
not because you didn't collect you
failed on her because at the moment she
offered to make that check you should
have said okay I'm gonna so you're gonna
send me that check yes and you're gonna
send it the middle of the month yes
because in Brandon's psychology the
minute that she promised to make that
payment we had kind of gotten her
because she'd committed to this and now
we could use that the next time he
called her anyway so there's a few calls
like that I was a very bad collector but
what I realized at the end was I could
afford to be a bad collector like I'm
married to a doctor I make a decent
living as a writer but if I were
desperate like some of these collectors
I would have gotten wise quick to what I
had to say and do to make folks pay that
they are desperate they are like sharks
I mean that's basically what you've
depicted here in a very clear manner
yeah I mean there's some collectors that
do well for themselves and work at more
of these kind of White Glove customer
service type places but a lot of
collectors are pretty desperate I mean I
was at one agency where and payday at
the end of the week one guy made a
hundred and fifteen dollars and another
guy made eighty-five dollars and that's
poor
yeah
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcast on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
so Jake you talked about this underworld
in Buffalo and and going up to Bangor
Maine and getting on the phones and
dealing with that sort of set of
characters then you also talked about
another pillar of the step collection
world which is Las Vegas and he went
there to do investigation there and to
deal with some of these individuals and
discover new things there what was that
like right so I wanted to see how
Brandon Wilson was buying this debt and
if you remember Brandon is the former
armed robber who works for Aaron and is
finding these deals on paper and those
deals are key to making the profit
margin so of course we're talking to
Brandon about where he you know hunted
or searched for paper he said Las Vegas
every February there's a big debt buyers
convention and I go out there and I hunt
for deals so I asked him can I tag along
and he said sure so in February 2013 I
flew out to Vegas and spent several days
with Brandon as he was on the prowl for
these deals he wanted to get a few
called these buckets of debt that he
could then bring home with him either to
work at his own collection agency or
that he could then flip and sell to
other folks and well it was interesting
because when we arrived there that year
that the market for debt was changing
for two reasons one was the regulators
were finally starting to crack down a
little bit and that was making some of
the the bank's nervous about who was
getting a hold of their debt the other
thing is that during the credit boom of
the 2000s credit was just everyone was
getting a loan and now all of a sudden
after the recession people are becoming
much creditors have become more careful
about who they issue credit to which
means that the cost of buying than these
bad accounts that no one collect on goes
up so all this meant that Brandon had to
work that much harder to find these
deals and when he was there he was
hunting for this paper that he called
the rink on paper - let me tell you a
little bit about that that's a really
interesting story okay so when he gets
there the word kind of on the street or
in the hotel lobby is that there's a
parcel of debt that
is calling the rink on paper and it it's
it's a debt that belonged to an agency
out in California known as rink on that
the Federal Trade Commission actually
shut down because they were doing all
kinds of illegal stuff in terms of
collecting and threatening abusing
debtors and after they shut down this
agency its assets went into a
court-appointed receiver the court kind
of the same way that you would cease
like a drug dealers car and auction it
off to raise revenue the same thing
happened but the assets that this Rincon
company had were largely their paper the
debt that they were collecting on so now
basically this court appointed Seaver
was auctioning off this this paper and
everyone was trying to figure out whom
how much is this worth it's a big piece
of debt so I'm going round with Brandon
he's kind of just doing his intelligence
talking to folks what do you know what's
the word on this rink on paper is any
good how much would you pay for it would
you pay one penny on the dollar but
she's pay a tenth of a penny on the
dollar that kind of thing and I'm with
him one day when he meets this woman who
is another debt broker and she and
Brandon wants to talk to her because she
used to sell debt to Rincon and she was
intimately familiar with the workings of
the company and she said don't buy it
and Brandon says I'm I kind of wasn't
gonna I had a bad feeling about it but
why do you're saying I shouldn't buy it
she said well I have reliable
information from the people at Rincon
that some of that debt was stolen after
the offices were shut down and what's
more that some of the chains of title
proving kind of legitimate ownership of
this debt is not there and I have this
information she claimed directly from
people inside Rane Khan and if you buy
that debt you're gonna be in a world of
trouble because particularly if it was
stolen
that means someone else could be working
the same paper that you own so I
eventually called up someone at the
Federal Trade Commission I said is it
possible that some of this paper was
stolen after the offices were shut down
and they basically said to me I can't
tell you for a hundred percent certainty
that some employee didn't walk out the
door with some of that paper before we
shut that down so then I went and I did
a little more digging and I look
at the terms of sale that the court was
was saying if you want to buy this paper
this is the greement you have to the pay
the contract you have to agree to it and
the contract said in pretty clear
language we are making no warranties or
guarantees about the accuracy or the
validity of this paper that's being sold
so basically to sum this whole thing up
you have a federal regulatory agency
shutting down a bad actor in the
business handing over its assets it's
paper to a court-appointed receiver and
there's an auction and they're selling
off that paper then and there's reason
to believe that at least possibly
they're selling paper that's been stolen
and it was kind of mind-boggling you
know these are people they're meant to
be cracking down and solving problems
might inadvertently be kind of creating
problems and in the end Brandon decides
that he just doesn't want to make a bid
on this on this rink on paper that's
that's owned by the that's being
controlled by this court appointed
receiver yeah I find that again
horrifying that the fti FTC is closing
down a shop yep taking that paper yeah
not doing anything with respect to I
imagine the debtors that are involved on
the other side of that paper because
they don't know what's going on with
their debt they don't know it's been
shut and moved to the going to somewhere
else and they could conceivably whether
it's for that paper other paper be
getting calls from collection agencies
that bought it stole it whatever that
they've never heard of that they never
had a transaction with you mentioned for
example chase in Washington Mutual as
two banks that at the top of a food
chain sort of right pad paper this is
different from the rink on example but
at some point
chase stops selling correct it's dead on
because of regulations that have come
into effect after the financial crisis
and with the dodd-frank act how did that
impact first well why did they do it was
with their other motives were the
lawsuits that they could have been
dealing with they didn't want to deal
with and also how did that impact this
whole chain of other characters that
were involved in in debt collection
right so so the time
the book is bad paper and bad paper is
just paper that there's problems with
and that that therefore it makes it hard
to collect and there's a lot of bad
paper out there because basically what
these big creditors like you know
Washington Mutual's now but now chase or
the or bank America whatever for years
have just sold these spreadsheets out
with a not a particularly careful or
organized way to debt buyers and the
contracts that these banks create when
they sell it to the debt buyers clearly
have these these crazy warranties in
then that say we're making no guarantee
about the accuracy of this information
and there's problems with it there's all
kinds of problems with and I saw that
firsthand with some of the the people
that are connected to the package that I
looked at in the book just to give you
one quick example there was a woman I
was connected to this package whose debt
after going through the whole circus of
what happened in Buffalo ends up in the
courts down in Georgia and she's getting
some it appears on her credit report and
she's in danger of being sued over it
and I meet with this woman and I say
okay what's the story with this debt and
she say she says I was hoping you could
tell me I don't recognize this
Washington Mutual debt that I supposedly
oh so I said okay there's got to be an
easy solution here let's call Chase Bank
which now bought Washington Mutual and
we'll just ask them directly what's
going on with this amount and with this
debt that you don't recognize so I call
up a spokesman for Chase and I say I
have this woman right here her name is
Julie she has this on her credit report
but she doesn't recognize the debt the
amount anything like that can you help
us clarify because when this was sold
off it appears maybe it was done in a
kind of the mistakes or what the guy
from James calls him back and says Jake
we've decided we're just going to write
off Julie's debt as fraud and I said
well why and he said well we don't have
any of the underlying documentation that
would give us confidence that this is in
fact a valid and accurate debt they had
some statements but they didn't have the
original signed contract or proof of who
was paying that that I said what do you
mean you don't have it like you're the
bank shouldn't you have it and he said
well when Chase acquired Washington
was a very rapid process and information
was lost now when chase acquired
Washington neutral that is one of the
largest financial acquisitions in recent
history and you're talking about a
pillar of the financial world and
they're basically saying you know what
we don't have this paperwork so the
mistakes that are being made that makes
this paper bad aren't just being
happening at the very bottom of the food
chain the debt food chain where you have
street hustlers in Buffalo there's every
reason to believe it's happening at the
very highest levels of Finance in our
assumption of my assumption going into
this that banks are not gonna be making
mistakes like this is not necessarily a
safe assumption to make I mean you you
were actually coming at this entire
story which is one of the reasons I
think it's it's the writing is just so
clear you're coming on it not from a
sort of financial component but really
from the ground up from from this
underworld you talk about and from the
individuals role in all of this and how
people are impacted the stories that
surrounded the Washington Mutual Chase
merger and everything that was happening
during the financial crisis of 2008 have
come into focus as being about this sort
of thing happening mostly with mortgages
with with attachments to mortgage loans
being lost with robo-signing and all
sorts of those kinds of things you
actually bring up that this is going on
and had been going on and has been going
on not just in mortgages but throughout
this entire credit spectrum went with
credit cards and other types right of
debt as well that's right I mean I think
at this point people know that there is
a lot of funny business going on with
the way that mortgages were issued the
way they were bought and sold the way
the houses were foreclosed upon it's
been in the press I think there's been a
lot less attention given to this idea of
consumer debt whether its credit card
debt or payday loans but there are the
same sorts of problems and in the way
where you see this in some ways the most
strikingly is when we get to the courts
which is where we get towards the end of
the book so basically all those folks
that are calling the debt collectors
that are calling saying you got to pay
this they're basically relying on the
talk off to convince you to pay but if
they can't do that then often it ends up
in
hands of lawyers who then sue on that
debt and this is where it goes to the
court and many of the same issues that
they've had with Robbo assigning with
the mortgages they're having similar
issues in court with credit cards
because basically the lawyers that are
suing on this debt the evidence they
have is fairly thin it's these Excel
spreadsheets and there's problems with
the Excel spreadsheets and but what
what's happens is is that there's a 90%
no-show rate rate with consumers in
courts so if you think about it here
it's just to make it like you know
simple I'm a guy Jake I can't pay my
credit card a whole bunch of debt
collectors call me up they bought and
sold my debt for pennies and cheap
around the dollar
I still can't pay it well eventually
they're bringing the lawyers and the
lawyers sue me for this amount
most likely what they're saying I owe is
much higher than the original principle
balance might be three times higher
because of the high interest rates so if
I go to court I can challenge that and
say where did you get this number and
you have proof that this is really my
debt or what's the breakdown of interest
in principle but 90% of Americans don't
show up in court they either don't
understand what it means not to show up
there they're there they feel there's no
point and what happens is if these
numbers on the Excel spreadsheet that
are highly suspect to begin with then
get stamped by the court and it becomes
a judgment against you and then your
creditor can now garnish your wages they
don't have to call you up and beg you to
pay they can go right at your bank
account and clean it out they can get
your monthly work check and this is
happening there's a new study that's out
by NPR and ProPublica that shows that
10% of Americans between 35 and 45 are
having their wages garnished every week
so that's what's happening yeah that's
astonishing so you've basically given in
this book in this interview in bad paper
to two very important pieces of advice
for for consumers out there who are
involved in this debt collection process
one if someone calls about a debt that's
over a certain period of time you should
be very suspect about that call and
likely ignore it and also
as you're mentioning now you should show
up in court if you get summons to court
because you have a much better chance of
writing whatever wrong you've been
involved in then if you simply don't
show up and it goes against you that's
totally true and and I'm not that that
in itself is a justice you have provided
through bad paper to I think the entire
American public so thank you for that
Oh behalf of the American public so you
you you were in in court you imagine
Savannah Georgia and and the kind of
history that Georgia has in the debtors
prison and the debtors idea of
reinstitution sorts of things and you
actually stood by some of these people
yeah it's interesting so the history was
that you know originally Georgia was
conceived as a kind of utopia that would
rehabilitate debtors they would come
from the debtors prisons in England and
come to the new world and get a fresh
start and kind of get out of the chains
of debt and rebuild their lives it was
this kind of very upbeat optimistic view
of reinvention kind of getting but the
irony is that that's really not the case
in America these days I mean we hear a
lot about how Americans can declare
bankruptcy and get out of their debts
but there's lots of people who are just
have horrible credit ratings therefore
pay higher rates on all kinds of loans
they take out their having their wages
garnished their checking accounts
cleared out it's quite a contrast to
this utopian vision that originally
founded the state of Georgia and then
the other part of your question which is
about you know going to court and there
was a fairly funny thing that happened
to me which was that I wanted to
actually see what this process was like
so I followed the package of debt that I
followed in the book and I went to one
of the courthouse where some of the
debtors connected this package had had
been through and I just showed up just
to kind of get a sense of it so I'm
waiting outside the courtroom and I
start talking with this couple who's
being sued over a credit card debt and
they don't recognize the people that
claim to own the debt that the creditors
name doesn't ring a bell for them and
the
doesn't make sense to them and there's
no documentation about the breakdown of
that amount we're trying to figure it
out
and this guy calls out their name a
young lawyer this is outside the
courtroom and he calls out their name
and they walk over there and he says to
them I represent the people that own
your debt and let's just settle this
basically let's just settle this right
now and we can work out an agreement and
you can pay me and we don't need to go
before the judge and they start he then
reaches into his briefcase and pulls out
this document that looks almost like a
credit card statement but kind of like a
mock up of a credit card statement all
it has is the amount they owe their name
their address and then the pop in bold
print it says this is not an actual
credit card statement okay so they're
kind of looking at this to see what this
is and they start talking to this lawyer
and at some point along the way I pipe
up and I say do you have any
documentation to prove that you do in
fact own this debt or any further
information that gives a breakdown of
the debt and he says to me are you a
lawyer I said no I'm just writing a book
and he said well you can't represent
them and in fact as this escalates he
says I'm gonna take you in front of the
judge so I returned to the courtroom
with this couple and the woman who
actually is on the hook for the debt the
judge calls her up and then she calls
the judge calls me up as well and we get
sworn in together kind of like we're
co-defendants in this and I'm it was it
was like a Kafka novel or something saw
sworn in and the lawyer who's suing on
this debt says procedures opening
arguments and says mr. Halpern here is
appears to be practicing law without a
license in your honor can you please
tell him that he could face criminal
sanctions for doing this and I say Your
Honor I just asked a question I'm trying
to figure out the process with these
folks that I met about 15 minutes ago so
this goes on for back-and-forth for a
little bit and finally the judge says to
this lawyer what do you want to do about
the matter of this debt that this woman
owes and he says let me consult with my
client he goes up makes a phone call
comes back and says Your Honor we're
gonna drop the case so at this point me
and the debtor looking to like what just
happened and we're kind of scratching
our heads we walk out into the hallway
and there's
guy there who's for Georgia legal
services and he says basically to us
I'll tell you what just happened you
said the magic words and the magic words
are prove your case in other words this
couple simply by showing up in court and
pressing back just a little bit asking
for the barest thinnest amount of
evidence of the legitimacy of this debt
and the detailed information of this
debt was enough to make the person suing
on it back off and the whole thing kind
of just crumbled and it was this moment
where it was so funny I had the whole
book I've been chasing this package of
debt this Excel spreadsheet through the
streets of Buffalo then I'm down on the
courts in Georgia and the moment it
comes under even the faintest bit of
scrutiny it's like it just vanishes into
nothing that's amazing now you mentioned
earlier that the whole chasing of paper
and the whole zealousness of the debt
collection business got to a larger
height during the the great recession
after the financial crisis because
people just simply had less money to pay
and they had more debts that had
accumulated and you talk about the term
the shadow economy for those people
which I find very interesting because
when we use the term shadow banking
usually it's it's about hedge funds it's
about you know cam and island tax
shelter type things and the shadow
economy is is something different and
it's it's it's something that you you
discuss with respect to the people on
the on the bottom of this and I want to
know if you can just talk about where
you think those people and and how
that's going to evolve going forward
from from where we are now right so this
happened the way that I kind of stumbled
into this is when I was down in Georgia
and I was looking at the lives of these
debtors who had basically were being
sued in court over this debt I wanted to
try to get a sense for what their lives
were like and one of them told me that
she bought her car from a special car
dealership that offered that catered
almost exclusively to people with bad
credit so I went out to this dealership
and what became clear was is that they
were paying an enormous premium for
their bad credit
in the words of this car dealer their
money was worth about 70 cents on the
dollar and a car that was maybe should
have cost $9,000 is gonna cost $13,000
in fact another debtor who I followed he
actually had his bank account cleaned
out he was one of these guys that there
was a judgment imposed against him they
found him and they cleaned out every
cent they had in a savings account which
was then in a cause and caused him to
default on his car payment which then
could compromise his ability to get to
work and his particular situation is he
had a device a GPS kind of device on the
engine of his car so the moment that he
went into default on this car loan which
he was paying this premium on boom the
engine would shut off in his car be
stuck at the side of the road so this is
this is the world that people inhabit
who have really bad credit and I went
and stayed at that I visited this
housing complex where was basically all
people who had very bad credit and yeah
they live in this world where they are
paying the highest possible rates of
interest and there's basically no no
trust creditors don't trust that they're
gonna pay the bills and so they get kind
of stuck with this and on the one hand
you can kind of understand it from the
creditors perspective these are very
risky investments but it's also pretty
hard to see people who are so poor
having much of their income devoured by
by interest and they're the ones that
are getting kind of the most gouged by
this and when you talk to the FTC or the
the Consumer Protection Board have you
gotten a sense that this is an issue
whatsoever at all that they're trying to
do something about helping yeah other
people on this side of the circuit and
also just just generally you know the
fact that there are such heinous
interest rates and the payday loans way
above yousry levels on other loans on
credit cards that continue to get
imposed on the people that have the
least ability to pay I think you
mentioned one instance which which is
very logical where one of the people in
your book says you know if I hadn't been
hit with D extra charge the extra ratio
I would have been able to pay this we
couldn't negotiate it everyone
you know this all could have not been
this chain of shadowy underworld
financial stuff do you sense any
understanding of trying to get to the
root of this matter at the Washington
level I think yeah I think the creation
of the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau which was the kind of brainchild
of now senator Elizabeth Warren was a
good move and they are starting to make
a difference in the space and they're
gonna have new rules coming on in about
a year that will affect debt collections
and they've they've been aggressive I
mean it isn't if I were in charge I mean
I would give them more funding I mean a
lot of this is going to come down to how
much resources do they have to kind of
go after the bad actors so the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau might have a
budget of I don't know between four and
five hundred million dollars but just to
put that in perspective
if you look at the amount of money that
JPMorgan Chase set aside for litigation
reserves in 2013 they see the amount of
money that they put aside to kind of
defend themselves the Consumer Financial
Protection bureaus budget is 2% of that
so you get the sense that they're doing
good work but they're kind of outgunned
here and I think that you know hopefully
if anything comes the book I mean I hope
it's a call to arms to kind of give them
a shot in the arm another thing that I
was on the phone the other day with
someone from the Justice Department they
have this operation this initiative
called Operation choke point and the
idea behind this is is to it's hard to
go after these the payday lenders that
do the worst stuff so what the Justice
Department has started to do is go after
the payment processors so if I'm a
payday collection agency and I'm doing
bad stuff I still have to rely on a
payment processor to take your credit
card or your debit card information and
take the money and the Justice
Department is started to say hey payment
processors if you are dealing with these
unscrupulous payday lenders we're gonna
go after you and there's been pushback
about that because there is a strong
payday loan lobbying presence and that
that is pushing back against this but I
think that you need
initiatives like that and we you know on
a larger scale if you're gonna see the
kind of change that needs to happen to
clean up the industry yeah and hopefully
yes and in reading your your book that
that chain is illuminated so well and
hopefully it can be a catalyst to at
least increasing the funding and to look
at these sorts of things in the under
your book and I guess towards the end of
how many years of research did this well
I have one fashion another I would say
it's been about four years I so at the
end of that time you go back to Buffalo
you can kind of do an epilogue on the
characters the individuals have been
involved on the debt collection side on
Aaron and Brandon on Jimmy and kind of
see where they are at the end of our the
most recent period of time what was that
like I think the most surprising thing
that I encountered in writing this kind
of wrap up this epilogue was that what I
found from Teresa who is the debt or the
former Marine if you remember and she's
the one that paid the wrong collector
the collector that had somehow gotten
ahold of her debt by theft so I was
curious about kind of where she was and
how she was doing and just as the book
was about ready to go into its final
version she called me up and said you're
not gonna believe this but I just got a
call from another collector on that same
debt which was puzzling because when
Erin Siegel who would was the rightful
owner of it had discovered that there
had been fraud he did the right thing
which was that he retired the debt he
kind of he didn't sell it he put it in a
hard drive and there rest in peace in
theory and yet someone was collecting on
this on this debt still so I called the
agency I wrote them a letter actually
that was that had contacted Teresa and I
said I'm inquiring about these calls
that you're sending to this woman
because they were threatening to sue her
what is your claim to ownership of this
debt and I thought I would get like I
didn't think I'd hear from anyone and I
thought if I did hear from someone I'd
hear from someone and like some you know
chop shop and you know buffalo or
something
turns out I talked to a guy the owner
lives in Beverly Hills and is doing very
well for himself
and when I
asked about this he kind of says let me
look into this oh yeah this debt belongs
to a portfolio of debt that I purchased
some a debt broker in Florida that was
double sold and a lot of the numbers
have been manipulated all these problems
of it and he and he but his attitude was
not shocked
but kind of like this is par for the
course in this business hey you're just
purchasing data and you never know what
you're purchasing and it was this kind
of chilling end to the whole thing
because of course you're not just
purchasing data you're purchasing the
right to collect on people's debts and a
profoundly affect their lives and
somehow or another the whoever stole it
from from Aaron must have sold it to
someone else as well and to this day
Theresa's debt is just floating around
there in cyberspace and someone else
will buy it and then try to collect on
it and somehow that that that more than
anything else just kind of seemed to
speak to the to the chaos and the
dysfunctionality of this industry yeah
so if you have to give one message to
consumers and to regulators to fix this
what is what is the takeaway I think
that the consumers is is that you have
to be skeptical of who's calling you on
the phone and you can't assume blindly
that they have a legitimate claim to
this debt or the v amount that they're
asking for is in fact accurate and you
have to do your homework and make sure
that you know that there's still a legal
obligation to pay this debt and and you
have to kind of the equivalent of
driving defensively with your financial
reaction to these calls on the larger
level there's a few things that need to
happen one is that there needs to be
better enforcement more resources for
places like this Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau to is the banks have
to be more careful about what they pass
along and make sure that information is
correct and there's all the
documentation there's supposed to be and
three I think that there needs to be a
change the way that this court system
works because the 90% no-show rate and
these all these default judgments is
creating these garnishments and all
kinds of problems so there's a
there's a fair amount that needs to be
done well I want to I want to thank you
for coming here today for writing this
book and for bringing this information
these stories of these individuals and
what happens to the people on all sides
of this debt collection chain and what
they can do and what should be done at
the higher levels of the country on a
regulatory basis I congratulate you for
writing it I loved reading it I read
this in a very quick setting I couldn't
really stop reading it and so thank you
for being on here thank you for writing
the book and the best of luck with it
thanks so much